obviously we know that Shazam choo is in
the works
did you might start production on that
and then have to pulp because warranty
we actually haven't started [ __ ] we
were set to start meeting this summer
all right so yeah we think of September
actually right mom oh you want to see
the new puppy Cassie but no we were
psyched we're set to start shooting this
summer so it's most likely gonna be
postponed but we'll see George King
George tell me about possibly the script
for Shazam - have you gotten to read it
hey George um can you tell her about the
script yeah oh he said I'm he yeah
what'd you say buddy you got it he
hasn't read it yet oh my god that's so
weird you haven't read the script me
either so we're so excited for you
though and obviously hopefully you know
you guys can start shooting and getting
back into the class have you been
keeping such with Zachary during
quarantine I have yeah we have has
access at his big big house big land
that he hasn't invited me to no you can
use like yeah it's it's the only it's
like the first thing I say every time I
call hey when when you get invite me out
things like oh you're a Buddhist just to
get through the college yeah I bet
you're excited to reunite with them
though for sure I will be crashing yeah
I'm like I said I'll just wait oh wait
Instagram what's the first thing you do
when you see are you like a house with
no invitation be like yeah it's like
maybe we can just go over the script
together hey I came all the way here so
we can like practice together yeah it's
like I've never met you before I really
need to just hang
Wiki Morgan we didn't we've never done a
movie together before I just I need more
of your work in chocolate great I love
it
[Music]